the penny farthing was the first machine
to be called a bicycle
[Music]
they're old they're funny and for some
still a big deal
sometimes I go into local bike shop just
for a bit of a joke and ask me if I got
a tire to fit my bike and bring them
outside have a look at it
[Music]
people find the funny filing almost
hypnotic I don't know why I can't
explain it but people just love seeing
it and it's just a real pleasure to
share it with people
Richard being an already avid bike racer
discovered penny-farthing racing on an
internet forum one night so I entered
immediately overexcited and then
realized that a hard elf a penny
farthing and B I don't how to ride a
penny farthing but he overcame those
hurdles I'm the current UK champion so
got title defend but penny farthing
racing isn't as easy as it looks and it
sure doesn't look easy it's a very
dangerous machine to ride you sat up on
top on the point of balance virtually so
if anything goes wrong you tend to be
going headfirst over the front of the
bike the bikes can be up to five feet
tall and that height has its benefits
Racing one of these bikes pretty high up
you get a fantastic view of the crowd
it's the best way to see the event here
I always tell people height is not the
only benefit the penny farthing has big
difference between riding and a penny
farthing and a normal bike is you can't
slow down very quickly you've got to
watch the road ahead but I find the
biggest difference is the smiles on
people's faces when you ride one of
these things people just love to see it
they smile they wave they pull up take
photographs so many conversations with
people I would never ever meet without
this bike and that's that's the joy that
people just love seeing and talking
about it
[Music]
[Music]
it's a rarity to go to a roller skating
rink and find live music there most
other roller rinks have gone digital but
head to Southern California and you'll
find one of the last remaining rinks to
employ a live organ player
[Music]
my name is Dominic Angelo si and I own
the moonlight Roller way I've been
playing rollerskating music for 70 years
there are only about 10 or 15 roller
rink Organists left in the country in
the 40s and 50s most of the rinks around
the country used live organ music and
then when Elvis Presley and the Beatles
all came into the picture in the 50s and
60s most of the rinks around the country
faced out the live organ to play
recorded music but not the moonlight
roller way Wednesday through Monday the
moonlight roller Way plays recorded
music just like most roller rinks but
one day a week Dominick gets to dust off
his Hammond organ and throw back to a
different time
on Tuesdays I play from 8 o'clock till
10:30 the people that come on Tuesday
nights are mixed crowd a number of the
skaters are old-time skaters in their
70s and 80s who like to skate to the
organ music this place is special
because it's been here for so long it's
a historical landmark people have skated
here through the years met their
boyfriends girlfriends here raised a
family bring their grandchildren and
it's something from the past and I just
want to hold on to at least one night a
week I love coming here I come every day
and I enjoyed my customers they
appreciate it and they like the music I
have no plans to stop playing the organ
I'll play it as long as I'm here
[Music]
[Music]
I'm skating with these women I feel on
fire
I love rollerskating so much that I
decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone i'm michelle stylin
better known as estrogen and i'm the
founder of moxie roller skates there are
21 skaters on the moxie skate team
worldwide but some of them are pigeon
Indy JAMA Jones
smelly and my legs anything that's
experimental or outside of what you've
probably seen on roller skates is what
we do roller skating was really really
big until I was born and then it really
kind of dropped off when rollerblades
came in roller skate innovation just
stopped
roller derby was the next new sport to
come to the roller skating industry this
meets that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed the
skate that we're making now are made for
secure landings for high-flying tricks
you know a few years ago there were like
gals doing backflips and on their own
wheels and now there are and I'm amazed
at what my body can do I really am we
are chasing our dreams we're chasing
that feeling that wonderful flirty
feeling of being alive and
you will get that from rollers skinny
it's this strange new feeling that's
refreshing ah this is its punching its
kicking armor combat is sort of like MMA
but with weapons to me this is the
ultimate combat sport my name is Andres
Inoue I'm the co-founder of the armored
combat league I'm the captain of the
national sword fighting team the USA
Knights our form of armored combat
started a little over four years ago it
came to our ears that there were some
people over in Europe that were doing
this and we had to build the United
States team and trying to be competitive
with the world most of the arms and
armor that we use comes from the late
14th in early 15th century Western
Europe now there's some other armors but
the best bang for the buck
it is usually late 14th century or early
15th century armor it's kind of
counterintuitive but if you're wearing
decent armor and you get hit with a
sword half the time you don't even know
you've been hit
if you played football you'd done a
rougher thing
it's a brawl I mean there's no doubt
about it you're going out there and
you're brawling just like in rugby or a
football you've got to have a plan when
you go out there the flankers end up
with three people on them and you end up
with two now melees are a lot more
intense those rules are you fight until
submission or until you put somebody
down to the ground there's no typical
person for armoured combat you've got
people from all walks of life whether
it's some sort of martial arts or
football or rugby there's some history
buffs too and they'll fight and fight
and fight and they'll give everything to
the point of exhaustion that's what
makes a winner it's all here these guys
will go hard at each other they're gonna
be swinging as hard as they can they're
trying to knock you down they're trying
to get you to submit and then they're
gonna help you up they're gonna patch on
the back and they're you'll have a steak
and a beer with you
[Music]
when you take a wriggly first things
come to your mind is the grass the
marquee out front and the school board
it's like one of the main body parts of
Wrigley Field I'm Darrell Wilson I'm a
scoreboard operator for Chicago Cubs
[Music]
I've been working at Wrigley Field since
1987
Brittany Phillips one of the oldest
ballparks besides Boston he's been
around for over a hundred years and
basically nothing has changed in the
school board since 1938 and the
scoreboard we have least three guys if
we're lucky for what a Cubs game is
going on my job is to post scores
anybody ending and pitching changes
throughout the league once all the games
start in the school board it's pretty
chaotic you're writing scores down on
your clipboard and you change the scores
where you're also yelling at other guys
to change their scores and their games
gets in oh it's hot it's a very noisy
the walkways are look narrow you got
plates numbers everywhere a switch up
the scoreboard plate starts with a chip
punch just three tips a pop it out of
the slot the plates are made of a
lighter thin metal you can definitely
out the latch if you want to make sure
that they're locked in so that the winds
blowing out they won't blow out at you
or something like that you're running up
and down and change the scores for eight
different games oh it's definitely hard
work if viewers outstanding us it's just
like a 360-degree view of the entire
ballpark and enable it that's like
looking out to your backyard and have
the perfect lawn I mean that's that's
what it's feel like you're walking out
you just feel feel proud you know you're
just proud of your work and the work
that you guys put into it the reason why
I believe that the school board is
special to fans because it still keeps
that old luster of the old-time ballpark
I seen a lot of modern parks but we
really feel has an authentic original
feel of how baseball began
you